congratulations to Adam and Raven that's
former bachelor Colton Underwood
reacting to some exciting engagement
news after two years of dating a
bachelor in paradise couple Raven and
Adam are set to tie the knot Adam and
Raven actually came to the date with TNI
in paradise and you could tell those two
loved each other and had our
appreciation for each other so I'm very
very excited for them from one happy
bachelor couple to a bachelorette
looking for love Colton weighed in on
Hannah B Cass and I were just with
Hannah last night I think she's doing a
fantastic job she's staying true to
herself and I think that's the most
important thing is there's really no
advice you could ever give somebody but
to do things your way you could tell
that she's happy
whether that means she walked away with
nobody or she walks away engaged she did
things and she made the decision that
was best for her as for Colton's love
life he's happily dating Cassie Randolph
who won his season of The Bachelor her
schooling is really important to her so
I'm there to support her right now
through her schooling she has two more
years left on her speech pathology
degree so she has that going on and
we're sort of just taking things in
stride I know we're gonna relax a little
bit enjoy the summer and really just be
in each other's company we have some
summer travel where we're gonna hit a
Vegas trip and then we're going back to
Thailand in the fall so it's gonna be
fun speaking of fun Colton is open to
the idea of doing Dancing with the Stars
but only under one condition I think
with my schedule right now I don't know
if it's in my deck of cards if I was
with Cass I would consider it if Cassie
can do it with me but I think it would
be something that would be such a cool
experience for Cassie to do I think she
would have a blast with it and she
always wanted to learn how to
so I think house would be great on
Dancing with the Stars et spoke with the
former NFL player at the first-ever
Critics Choice reel TV Awards The
Bachelor was nominated for best
relationship show I think it's awesome
just to see the show up for a nomination
because I know how many people it takes
to do a show to that caliber and to see
everybody from the camera operators to
audio guys to the producers sacrificed
so much for human beings to find love
like it's it's really cool and it's
really special